TYRA: Becoming a top model
is a dream shared by girls
all across America.
I am going to be the first
black plus-size supermodel.
I've been waiting
for this moment.
Are you gonna be
a model someday?
- Mm-hmm.
- Why?
Because I want to.
( music playing )
TYRA: America's Next Top Model
is about giving those girls
a chance to make
their dream a reality.
America's Next Top Model
is Adrianne.
( music playing )
TYRA: Yoanna is America's
Next Top Model.
Aah!
TYRA: That doesn't mean
it's gonna be easy.
( sobbing )
Bitches.
TYRA: Out of thousands
of girls who applied,
only a select few
made it to the semi-finals
in Los Angeles.
( screaming )
TYRA: Over a week
of grueling interviews.
Most of those girls are like,
"Oh, I'm fat."
I'm like,
"You know what? You are."
Like, I don't know
what to tell you.
TYRA: Wild nightlife.
Aah!
WOMAN: That skank ho
poured a beer
on my ( ... ) weave.
TYRA:
And good old-fashioned drama.
I'm glad I'm not you, bitch.
( screaming )
I'm legally blind.
TYRA: I picked my final 14
to move to New York
and compete for the title
of America's Next Top Model.
Now five girls remain,
Amanda, Ann, Eva,
Norelle, and Yaya.
Tonight, the episode
you must not miss.
Find out how it all went down
as we count down
to the final five.
Plus amazing model moments
you've never seen before,
including a tearful confession
from Cassie.
( crying )
I didn't want to hurt you,
like, asking for money.
WOMAN: Oh, Cassie.
I mean, I hope
you haven't done anything.
TYRA: Yaya, goes ballistic.
I can't hear!
I'm on the phone!
TYRA:
And the diva confrontation.
YAYA: I don't feel
negativity towards you.
I just don't feel anything.
( music playing )
MAN: ♪ Oh! ♪
♪ Oh! Yeah ♪
♪ Oh! ♪
♪ Oh! Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh!
Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ You want to be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na
na na, na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
( music playing )
TYRA: The search for
America's Next Top Model
started fast and furious
with a photo shoot
in Jamaica.
One of you will be eliminated
based on your performance today
in this photo shoot.
Time to work.
( music playing )
TYRA:
For their first photo shoot,
some of the girls got off
to a rocky start.
LEAH:
The competition's starting,
and it's hard
because I see other girls,
and then you start
comparing, like,
they have more fashion
knowledge than I do.
You have to be
really secure with yourself.
They don't have my size today?
I'm hearing rumors that,
you know,
they don't have my size.
I am only
the plus-size girl here.
But whatever they put me,
I'm gonna work it.
All right. Here it comes.
Ta-dah!
Holy crap.
- You look hot.
- I am hot, mama.
I look at myself,
and I'm like, "I'm fabulous."
( music playing )
Whoo.
JAY: That one feels a little
like you're taking a dump.
I wanna try something
a little more animalistic,
a bit savage or something.
Think of an animal.
Do you think animals do this?
Ooh!
Look at this.
I thought the bathing suit
was dope.
As soon as I putted it on,
I was like, "Oh, no."
So I really wasn't focused
like I should be.
NIGEL: Okay.
This is gonna be a hard one,
'cause she has no neck.
JAY: Lose the question mark
in the face.
TYRA: Magdalena couldn't
bring out the fire in her eyes.
NIGEL: Okay, you're opening
your eyes to wide.
TYRA: While Leah struggled
to find the right rhythm.
JAY:
Don't move the head too much.
Don't lose your pose too much.
( music playing )
TYRA: The next morning,
Mr. and Miss J
delivered the bad news.
This envelope
has one name in it.
And this girl
has to pack her bags right now.
Off to the airport,
you're going home.
( music playing )
Magdalena.
I wanted to read my name
if it was my name.
I'd have been like,
"This is a mistake right here.
Excuse me. Do you
have another envelope?"
WOMAN: "Guys, this is wrong."
EVA: I feel bad, you know,
that she had to go
but this is a competition,
and people are gonna go.
Everybody's gonna drop.
And then they're
in their jeans.
Aah! We're going to the house!
( music playing )
TYRA: Arriving back in New York,
the 13 girls moved
into their new home
at the famous Waldorf-Astoria.
Oh! Oh, my God!
( indistinct chatter )
NORELLE: Oh, my God the wall.
TOCCARA: The house
is absolutely gorgeous.
TYRA: By now, Ann and Eva
were fast friends
and wanted to share a room.
( music playing )
ANN: Girls were grabbing bags
and stuff
and I was waiting for Eva.
Look what I found.
TYRA: With all the beds claimed,
Eva was content with
an extra bed in the living room.
EVA: I got my bed.
Ann threw a big hissy fit.
ANN: I'm hurt because you didn't
stick up for me.
EVA: How did I not stick up...
- Because you didn't say ( ... )
- EVA: That's not true!
- No, Eva...
- EVA: If you wanna bitch
and moan about everything,
Ann, that's you.
That's not my personality.
ANN: Look, I love you.
- I will be friends with you...
- EVA: Stop, Ann.
I know. No, I--
you'll be in my wedding,
like, I swear to God.
I want you to win this
more than I want me to win this.
Okay, shut up!
WOMEN: Aww!
EVA: Ann is codependent.
Ann needs Eva to survive.
YAYA:
It was just extra dramatic.
It was extra dramatic like
they've been friends for years,
and I was like,
"Wow, this is..."
KRISTI: You know
what's gonna be funny?
When one leaves.
Mm-hmm.
KRISTI: Well, it had to be.
If Ann stayed--
because if Eva wasn't around,
Anna would flip out.
If Ann leaves, Eva doesn't
give a ( ... )
Right.
That would be funny.
TYRA: The next day,
the girls met with the judges
for the second elimination.
Janice learned some surprising
news from Toccara.
When I was in high school,
I did modern dance
and jazz and tap.
When I got a little older,
I did a little exotic dancing.
JANICE: I knew it! I knew it!
She's standing there!
Give us some, Janice.
Do it!
Exotic dance.
For him--If I could
do that for him.
Hello?
TYRA: But in the end,
it was between Leah and Ann.
JANICE: Your face, flawless,
but the passion behind it, zero.
TYRA: The pose sucks.
The photographer said
that you rolled your head a lot
and your rhythm was off.
It has to be roll,
snap, roll, snap.
And you were snap, snap.
Got it.
TYRA: The judges thought Ann
had more potential
so Leah was sent home.
( music playing )
TYRA: Being a top model is about
more than just a pretty face.
You have to have the look.
So I sent the girls to the salon
for a complete makeover.
All right, are you guys ready?
- ALL: Yes!
- TYRA: All right, let's go!
( music playing )
( gasps )
I'm interested to see
how it'll look.
I'm very open-minded about it.
( crying )
I hate short hair on me.
TYRA: Once again, some girls
weren't happy to be made over.
MAN: Are you ready? I'm gonna
cut it all off in one swipe.
( laughing and crying )
Yeah, I don't comb my hair
out like that.
It has to be from the tip
to the root.
Do you wanna do it?
I'd rather do it.
( music playing )
AMANDA: I would describe my look
as Donatella Versace
meets Lord of the Rings.
TYRA: Amanda loved
her radical transformation,
but it frightened
some of the other girls.
Her eyes are too blue,
and her hair is just--
it's scary.
I mean, I don't wanna be
around her at nighttime
when she's walking down
the hallway.
( music playing )
TYRA: After winning
the makeup challenge,
Norelle and her roommates
got to work it
at an industry party.
Come on girls. Let's go.
TYRA: While the other girls
just had to work.
I'm doing trash duty.
And I'm just worried about it,
because I'm legally blind.
KELLE:
I'm sorry, I can't do trash.
- AMANDA: It's fine.
- KELLE: I'm so--I'm sorry.
Amanda wanted to switch.
She storms off into the bathroom
and gets all upset.
I just don't want
to embarrass myself
in front of everybody,
like, run into something
or hurt myself
or knock somebody over.
I go up to her and say,
"I'll switch with you, Amanda."
( music playing )
Oops.
YAYA: It didn't seem that dark
outside to me.
- I had a great experience.
- I did too.
I wish had been out
a little bit more.
Trash, trash, trash.
YAYA: She just assumed
that it was gonna be a terrible,
terrible situation
for her to be in.
( music playing )
MAN: Perfect.
Pretty.
TYRA:
The next day, the girls faced
one of the most challenging
photo shoots for any model,
no makeup at all.
MAN: Nice right there, good!
I love that right there.
TYRA: Cassie revealed
a disturbing secret to Amanda.
JENNIPHER: The thing with Cassie
is she informed Amanda
that she was bulimic.
Amanda told somebody,
and next thing you know,
everybody knows, of course.
Like, that is not healthy.
Little girls can't think that,
"Oh, I wanna be a model.
Like, I'm gonna have
to make myself puke."
TYRA: Despite her troubles,
Cassie's photo turned out to be
one of the best.
That's perfect.
It kind of looks like
you're looking
at your boyfriend or something.
But Julie got in hot water
with the Judges.
JANICE: I wanna know
why you want to be a model?
JULIE: Honestly,
it's for me to start my own
apparel manufacturing company.
I was extremely turned off
when she said she was using
the modeling world
to get somewhere else.
So we decided to send her home.
With one secret revealed
to the girls,
Cassie felt it was time to make
a confession to her mother.
And I wanna tell you
everything, Mom, I do.
But it's--
I hate feeling
like I'm lying to you.
It's been a while
since I've been able to be
honest with my mom.
She doesn't know
that I'm a stripper.
I've just done some things--
I've done some things
to hurt myself,
so I wouldn't have to hurt you.
Financially,
I didn't want to hurt you,
like, asking for money.
MOM: Oh, Cassie.
Honey, I hope you haven't
done anything.
Nothing bad, but I'm sure
you won't approve of it.
That's what I'm trying
to tell you...
MOM: Stripping?
You don't do it anymore, do you?
- Mm-mmm.
- MOM: Oh, thank God.
I do not want you living
that kind of life.
CASSIE: I feel better
that I told her about it,
but I know that just
the one conversation
we had today
isn't the end of it.
TYRA: A top model
has to have a fierce walk,
so I sent the girls
to the top runway trainer
in the industry,
Miss J. Alexander.
J: Welcome to Runway 101.
Eva, you walk like you're
chewing gum between your legs.
I love it.
It's really funny,
because it's about to fall,
but you're not
letting it happen.
It's not gonna fall.
J.: Uh-oh!
( music playing )
J.: Yaya, you stayed too long
at the end.
You don't wanna
change the season
and never move off the stage.
You don't wanna go
fall, winter collection,
and then say, "It's spring,
summer, she's still there."
Kristi, I think that her look
is quite dead.
You are serving
a plate of steam
and a bowl of nothing.
( music playing )
TYRA: The girls put their lesson
to the test
at a private fashion show
for Heatherette.
( applause )
EVA: I was so high
being on stage.
And that's why
I wanna be a model,
because I want to do runway.
Though I'm short,
I love runway.
It's so fly to me.
Nobody's fallen down yet,
right?
( music playing )
MAN: She just fell down.
NORELLE: My biggest dream,
Heatherette fashion show,
my worst nightmare, falling,
all in the same night.
Thank goodness I fell
by a pole.
( applause )
HEATHERETTE: But that's gonna
make you a star, baby.
( music playing )
TYRA: Miss J. stopped by
to announce the winner
of the Heatherette
runway challenge.
Miss Eva.
Oh, yes!
J.: You nailed it.
In y'all tall bitches' face.
TYRA: Some of the other girls
were not too happy.
I just didn't like it
when you get up
and you tried to do it
in everybody's face.
You're like,
"You skinny bitches."
EVA: I didn't say skinny,
I said tall.
JENNIPHER: Why don't you go
around and ask every person...
- But why don't you go...
- Why don't you go around
- and ask every person?
- KRISTI: I do!
- NORELLE: No, you don't.
- EVA: No, you don't.
- I don't feel...
- Get out of the way.
Don't ever touch me again,
or else
you will get knocked out.
Oh, I'd like to see it.
JULIE: And it's crazy,
because you're the only one
that has even said that
that was rude.
How was that rude?
J.: You nailed it.
EVA:
In y'all tall bitches' face.
JENNIPHER: Okay, tell me.
- The comment...
EVA: I have to fight.
As much as y'all
don't wanna believe it,
I am a real person.
( music playing )
TYRA: The next day
before the photo shoot,
Toccara got a personal lesson
from Miss J.
So it's like I need
to bounce here
and not bounce this.
Okay. Let me see the bounce.
You just have to stop...
TOCCARA: Yeah.
J.: You need
to just go toe-heel.
- Toe-heel?
- Mm-hmm.
But this is not--
I'm not used to it.
It's just--Toccara is just...
I'm, like, so sorry
that I can do it
and you can't.
Give me two days.
Okay, guarantee, bitch.
Two days.
( music playing )
TYRA: Then the girls took it off
for a topless group photo shoot.
JAY: One.
JAY: Norelle, cover your breast
just a little bit better.
( music playing )
TYRA:
Kristi didn't feel confident
about posing in the nude.
KRISTI: I was really nervous.
I was trying to act
all comfortable and confident
when I totally was not.
JAY: Kristi, face towards
the camera just a little bit.
Just rotate your face
a touch more onto camera.
All the way this way?
JAY: No, that's too much.
( music playing )
TYRA: At judging,
Kristi's lack of confidence
showed in her photo.
JANICE:
I think you need more attitude.
See the smile?
That's--That's a confident
smile. It's so pretty.
It's, like, not coming
as fast as I would like.
- NIGEL: Fake the confidence.
- Fake it till you make it.
TYRA: And the judges
decided to send her home.
( music playing )
TYRA: To be a top model,
you have to know
how to strike a pose.
And who better
to teach the girls than
Miss Janice Dickinson herself.
With the stomach in.
Whoo-hoo!
Watch the arched eyebrow that
you're doing every single time.
That's okay.
Take two extra seconds and go...
relax and then go into it.
( music playing )
No, you're pulling your hair
too far back,
looks like the migraine.
Take your hands and stick them
right into that
wild hair of yours
like you're looking for lice.
Kind of, jut it forward.
Suck in the stomachs.
Okay, you step out.
EVA:
Take Jen out of the photo.
Jen, you better wake up, honey.
You can do better
even in Idaho.
What will be the biggest flaw
in wearing no panties
in a Marc Bouwer Gown
at all times?
WOMAN: Suck in your gut.
JANICE: Suck in your stomach.
Thank you.
Suck in your gut.
All right?
TYRA: And Kelle had trouble
bringing expression
into her face.
You got to really work
on your face.
Go through
all sorts of looks,
because you're doing
the same one look.
KELLE: It was discouraging,
because I had been taking
such horrible pictures,
and it's like,
"Well, maybe you are not as cute
you thought you were."
( music playing )
TYRA: The next day,
the girls had to put
Janice's lesson to the test
for Barney's creative director,
- Simon Doonan.
- But we're gonna put you
in the window of La Perla
in front of the whole
of New York City.
JENNIPHER: Oh, God, you know,
everyone's gonna see my butt.
( music playing )
I'm feeling pretty good,
especially since I've been
practicing a lot in the mirror.
I have, like,
a new focus point today.
SIMON:
Kelle just seems very natural.
Everything she's doing
seems effortless.
Okay, next.
( music playing )
SIMON: Jennipher,
she's a little dull/very dull.
Jennipher,
you have a great body,
but you look like you'd had
a Quaalude or something.
The winner of $5,000
at La Perla is Kelle.
( cheering )
TYRA:
She chose Amanda and Toccara
to share in the lingerie prize.
Instead of these gals
rummaging through the store,
you guys are gonna give us
a fashion show.
Oh, wow.
Is this apple cider?
To lingerie. To big panties.
ALL: Big panties.
Very chic. Oh, hello.
I'll take it.
I'll take that.
- I'll take that.
- SIMON: Gorgeous.
I'll take that in a medium.
I want your panties.
Can I get in in the large?
Oh, wow.
This is just great.
It was--It was perfect.
( music playing )
TYRA: A top model has to be
in great physical condition,
so the girls
had regular workouts
with their trainer, Savvas.
One, two, three.
ANN:
Our heart trainer Savvas
kicked our ass today.
Right, to one.
Don't stop, don't stop.
EVA: We're just a-movin'
and a-bouncin'.
My food going up and down.
I started coming up.
SAVVAS:
Don't go all the way up.
AMANDA: I haven't worked out
since high school.
That was seven years ago.
That's--no, no.
No!
SAVVAS: Go! Down!
I want the nine now!
SAVVAS: Oh!
( music playing )
TYRA: The girls kept on rolling
with the punches
at the photo shoot
the next day.
The more acrobatic you can be,
the better.
I'm talking, you know,
legs up, whoa!
All that type of stuff.
And that's gonna happen.
( music playing )
MAN: Beautiful, Norelle.
Now you're on. Now you're on.
Love that, love that.
Oops.
Whoa, whoa, careful, careful.
Oh, up, up, up.
Careful, careful,
careful, careful.
TYRA: Jennipher
did fine on the skates,
but had trouble bringing energy
to her face.
MAN: More energetic,
more energetic.
Have fun with this.
Mama needs fun.
Come on, I wanna see that.
JENNIPHER: This scares me.
Jennipher is a pretty face,
but it starts and stops there.
TYRA: And Jennipher's
inability to show
the desire to be a top model
got her sent home.
JENNIPHER:
If I don't wanna be here,
I wouldn't have left everything
I had back home to come here.
I would have
went home right now.
TYRA: With so many girls
under one roof,
the house is bound to get dirty,
but everyone agreed
that Cassie was the messiest.
AMANDA: Right now,
Cassie is the pretty much
the sloppiest one.
She's a sloppy slut.
ANN: Cassie had made brownies,
and they were sitting
on the counter
with all of the stuff out
that she used to make them.
I wrote with a knife
in her brownies.
"Clean your ( ... )"
Can you read that?
KELLE: Yes. Yes.
CASSIE:
It's so mind-boggling to me,
because who writes
in someone's food?
- Who wrote that?
- KELLE: I don't know.
( music playing )
And no one would admit
to the incident
Brownie-gate '04.
I wish whoever did it
would admit to it.
TOCCARA: It's hilarious because
whoever did it won't say it.
That's hilarious,
but I ain't rattin' on nobody,
I ain't nobody's rat.
I made some brownies today,
and someone wrote "clean
your ( ... )" on my brownies.
They think that
I don't clean my dishes
or something in the kitchen.
No one will fess up to it.
Oh.
Well, I wanna stand up
for myself,
but I don't know what to say.
( music playing )
TYRA:
When the girls went out to eat,
the truth came out.
WOMAN: Yaya, what is that?
YAYA: It's "respeito."
In Portugese, it means respect.
There's a big
lack of it in the house,
so I felt the need
to wear it today.
Okay, that's fine.
It was a joke, I'm sorry.
I crossed the line.
I was trying to be funny.
I thought you could--I thought
you would think it was funny.
Some people think
it's funny to kill people.
That doesn't make it funny.
I mean, we don't have to be
hostile to each other,
but don't touch my stuff
because it's not funny to me.
Okay, when you were making
yourself throw up,
and you didn't want anyone
to talk about it,
you said that,
and we stopped talking about it.
So stop talking about me,
because I don't like it.
I'm gonna talk about you,
I'll tell you that now.
ANN: Well, then I'm gonna talk
about how you're bulimic.
Who wants to live with
your dishes in the same...
CASSIE:
Who wants to live with you, Ann?
Okay, well don't
touch my ( ... )
I don't need you to tell me
to wash my ( ... ),
and I don't need you put
a knife in my brownies
and write "clean your ( ... )"
Don't ever touch my stuff.
YAYA: There are obviously
a lot many different levels
of maturity and experience
in this house,
but respect.
Respeito is the issue.
( music playing )
EVA: And so why are y'all mad?
Why is it her problem?
ANN: She's gonna be like,
"Why the ( ... )
were you immature?"
EVA: Yeah.
ANN: Lighten up.
TYRA: Back home,
Eva wanted to clear the air,
so she went to Yaya to discuss
the tension in the house.
YAYA: I don't know, really.
I don't understand why you're
coming and talking to me.
But I can be around everyone,
and the only
negative energy I feel
is coming from you.
And that's why
I'm talking to you.
I don't feel
negativity towards you.
I just don't feel anything.
I have very low tolerance,
and I build a wall
between people,
and they don't exist
in my world.
That's just how I am.
And I don't think
I'm a cold person.
I'm warm, but I also--
It's easy for me to just say,
"You know,
I don't wanna be bothered."
YAYA: You think I'm cold?
YAYA:
In reaction to something...
TOCCARA: Yeah, yeah.
- Stupid being said.
- EVA: Yeah.
EVA: I know you're planning
on being in this house
for a while and so do I.
And, I mean,
you can still feel that way.
You're entitled to that.
But I prefer there be more
understanding
and there be less tension,
because I think
it's unnecessary.
YAYA: It was interesting, yeah.
I'll just leave it at that.
( music playing )
TYRA:
At the high-flying photo shoot,
Yaya struggled
for the first time.
According to some
of the panelists,
my photos look like a dancer.
I was looking
at a dancer sometimes,
not a model.
So I tried to strip that away.
PHOTOGRAPHER: Three!
JAY: Yaya took her advice
from the panel
and took it to the extreme,
which in that case
isn't helping her.
( music playing )
PHOTOGRAPHER:
Amanda was beautiful.
Amanda was doing
dancer-like poses,
and Yaya was getting
pissy over there.
Every week,
I get the same comment, like,
there goes that dancer thing.
You shouldn't take everything
as a hard and fast rule, like.
Do you know what you're
gonna end up with?
Nothing to do.
TYRA: Kelle, again, was hampered
by her insecurities.
KELLE: I just--
I don't deal well with, like,
"Yeah, you're doing great,"
because I'm not really
doing great.
But, you know,
at the same time, Kelle,
I can't baby you
through every frame.
KELLE: I need help.
I've never done this before.
If I could take perfect photos,
I knew what I was doing,
I'd be in an agency.
( music playing )
TYRA:
At judging, I caught Janice
with her pants down.
Miss Janice is naked
underneath the table.
Well, just because
you've got couture,
I mean,
I'm not standing up, like...
TYRA: Look at that.
I love it.
JANICE:
I'm sitting on a cushion,
and I'm judging just fine.
- I'll put my ass on the table.
- TYRA: No, Janice.
JANICE: And I'll judge
like this, a'ight?
Because I got the best legs
going here, huh?
That's what I'm talking...
TYRA: Judge the photo, Janice.
With elimination looming,
even Ann blew off some steam.
Janice Dickinson!
- Help.
- Oh, I can't even watch.
I just can't look at it.
I need blinders.
This is, like, this is a--
she looks like a flea bit...
I've been on the cover of...
Vogue, Elle,
French Vogue, British Vogue!
Vogue covers, honey,,
in every country
and Cosmo and Elle.
So you think you're a model?
JANICE:
Why do you wanna be a model?
Why you want to be a model?
So, tell me,
why do you wanna be model?
Aah ha ha!
- Honestly...
- Please don't kill us.
We love you.
- We love you.
- This is all in good fun.
She'll laugh at this...
I think.
TYRA: When it came time
for Kelle's evaluation,
things turned serious.
I can't even look at it.
It's that bad.
TYRA: I struggle with,
is she photogenic
or is she not photogenic?
She's not photogenic.
TYRA: The judges decided
to send Kelle home.
KELLE:
It's disappointing to fail,
me being the type of person
that usually excels
in things that I do.
It's been a hard time for me.
There's only so much
humiliation I can take.
( music playing )
TYRA: Until a model
goes on her first go-sees,
no one in the fashion world
knows she exists.
So I made appointments
for the girls to see five
of the top designers
in the city.
( music playing )
So how did you
pick the name, Yaya?
That's so unusual.
It's actually really common
in West Africa.
Oh.
Norelle, that's a cute name.
NORELLE:
Let's hope that they see, like,
some potential in me.
NICOLE: No, no, no.
Stop right there.
TYRA: Toccara discovered
that haute couture
is not one-size fits all.
TOCCARA:
I'm gonna be the first black
plus-size supermodel
in the world.
She's got to, like,
break ground
if she wants to do something
kind of mainstream fashion.
It's not easy ground
to break, but... ( chuckles )
CASSIE: Diane Von Furstenberg
is really kind of cold
and intimidating,
'cause she's so powerful.
Now, I want you
to go back, walk.
I had on a dress
that didn't fit at all.
It was, kind of,
it was falling down in the front
but we had to walk for her
and make it work.
Don't do any of that.
No, no, no.
TYRA: Other girls discovered
haute couture
is not easy to walk in.
All right. Let's try that again.
Whoops.
TYRA: Cassie had to face
some harsh criticism.
MARC: I think that your thighs
are a little big for this dress.
Normally we like about
no more than 35.
I think I'm right at that.
We're at 39.
Okay. I prefer a smaller hip.
CASSIE: This week,
I have had to think a lot
about whether or not
I should be here.
( music playing )
TYRA: The next day,
the girls found
a hip-hop Miss J.
waiting for them
at the photo shoot.
And so today,
we have someone here
because Jay Manuel
will not be here today.
So, we have somebody else.
Come on out.
- Okay!
- Hello!
You better all give it
up for me.
- I've been up since dawn.
- (screaming )
CASSIE: He looks like a woman,
and that's not stuff
you see every day in Oklahoma.
TYRA: Jay Manuel's drag show
illustrated the day's
photo shoot, alter egos.
JAY: Good. Yeah.
( music playing )
PHOTOGRAPHER:
Brava, Eva. Very good.
JAY: Very...yes.
Face up to the light,
show the butt.
( music playing )
PHOTOGRAPHER:
Nice. Yes, yes, yes.
Hold right there.
TYRA: Nicole was not happy
with her assigned wardrobe.
NICOLE: Am I have gonna have
to wear this?
STYLIST: I'm gonna see.
The stylist had me
wearing some fur.
I just really can't wear fur.
I really will not
and cannot do it.
I know that
you're not deliberately
being a jerk to me,
but the thing is,
you're in the field of modeling.
No matter what her opinions
about what she has on,
she needs to act like it is
the best thing
since sliced bread.
( music playing )
WOMAN: No, you don't.
TYRA: Toccara was disappointed
with the lack of options
for her full figure.
Here I am, looking like
I work at Home Depot.
STYLIST:
I don't think that you realize
how this whole modeling thing
works and that...
- Oh, my God!
- Oh, sorry.
- Are you okay?
- Yeah.
- All right, you got pinched.
- TOCCARA: I'm okay.
JAY: Look at her.
She's a parking attendant.
JAY: Good.
You got such a beautiful face,
but your eyes can read dead.
TOCCARA: I should have
kept a positive attitude.
Like, "Okay." I don't know.
I really let it get to me.
I think it's just hard
because I'm very--
just trying to be so grateful,
and just be so grateful,
but it hurts.
TYRA: Miss J.
tried to cheer up Toccara
as only he could.
Everyone knows here
I'm the big girl.
Everyone knows
I'm a plus-size girl.
It's your fault
because you're fat, bitch.
Put her fat ass
in the clothes,
feed her
some more fried chicken
and baked macaroni and cheese
and cake.
- Time to feed me.
- You know, you have that--
Make the Kool-Aid
with five pounds of sugar,
and they're gonna put you
in industrial-size slippers.
- Strategy.
- Hmm.
Work it out.
Now you got
all these bony bitches
you gotta deal with.
And I say,
take them boney bitches
and knock them in the head.
What you got to do
is you gotta use this.
It's huge!
TYRA: The judging came down
to Cassie and Toccara.
NIGEL:
Cassie, this kind of prettiness
in a girl is a dime a dozen.
Toccara, there's just
something about her.
- She's interesting.
- Yeah, a lot of flesh.
TYRA: But the panel decided
that Toccara wanted this more.
Thanks, Cassie.
CASSIE: I was just being me,
and my personality
isn't bubbly.
They were just saying they
wanted more energy from me,
and I guess I wasn't
giving it to them.
( music playing )
TYRA: As a model,
you never know when or where
the public will see you,
so you have to look good
all the time.
REBECCA: Pick out
your favorite five things.
TYRA: Stylist Rebecca Weinberg
stopped by the house
to give the girls
a lesson in personal style.
You know, I have to say,
when I look at these things,
they look a little cheap.
This is, like, so high school.
Girl, you gotta grow up.
You're, kind of,
a little bit country,
- a little bit rock 'n' roll...
- EVA: I am everything.
REBECCA: That's a lot of pants.
( music playing )
REBECCA: Very Earth mother.
TYRA: Yaya found her ideals
coming into conflict
with Rebecca's advice.
REBECCA: I think you're exotic.
Your clothing,
your top is very exotic,
and I think that that's
important to you.
But yet,
I see no variety necessarily.
I hate the word exotic
with a passion.
- NICOLE: I know. I remember...
- So I'm just sitting there,
I was,
"Keep a straight face ahead.
Keep a straight face."
Don't exoticize me.
This is me. I'm not some animal
in the jungle.
Don't look at me
like I'm in the zoo.
( music playing )
Flex, flex.
TYRA: The next day,
the girls worked out
with their trainer, Savvas.
Keep distant your heels,
bend your knees.
Your kneel--Your heels.
Keep a distance.
ALL: Exhale down,
inhale up,
exhale down.
There.
You guys gonna stop
making fun of me or what?
EVA: "You're gonna work
your butts today."
( laughing )
So funny.
You realize that Savvas
didn't think that was funny
when we were working out,
doing Pilates?
- WOMAN: Yeah.
- Just making sure.
TOCCARA: Wait, what do you mean,
his accent?
I love his accent.
- Who said what?
- It doesn't matter who did it.
It was enough
for him to be like,
"What, is this
an English class?"
You know what I mean?
I just can't wait
'till we travel and we--
where everyone here
doesn't speak the language,
so you can feel
what it feels like,
because it's not cute.
WOMAN: Thank you.
TYRA:
The next morning, the girls
left for their photo shoot,
and when they got there,
there was a surprise
waiting for them.
We do have someone else for you
to pose with today in your shot.
So can we have
our other person?
( music playing )
Yeah!
Are we posing with her
or the spider?
- JAY: The tarantula.
- ANN: Yes!
JAY: The tarantula is very safe,
but we do have EMS
on the side...
What do you mean it's very safe?
Why would you have to have EMS
if it's safe?
We have EMS here all the time.
EVA: I don't like spiders.
I don't want them to touch me.
I don't want to be near them.
It's a horrible phobia
I've always had.
I'm really iffy right now.
( music playing )
Give me more life.
TYRA: Once again,
Ann struggled
to get a decent shot.
PHOTOGRAPHER: There's not
enough behind the eyes.
Don't force it, don't force it.
TYRA:
Toccara's signature sparkle
seemed to be fading.
MAN: Wide eyes, bigger eyes,
bigger eyes.
PHOTOGRAPHER: That's the most
fierce that she's looked.
That's it.
I mean, I did the best I could.
JAY: You all right?
I'm fine.
Please just leave me alone.
I'm have to do this makeup.
TYRA: When it came to posing
with the spiders,
Eva couldn't hold back
the tears.
She's crying.
Really?
EVA: I'm so sorry.
JAY: Ready to shoot
a little more?
Okay. Just keep
those there. Ready?
Mm-hmm. Let's go.
TYRA: But she mastered her fear
long enough to finish the shoot.
PHOTOGRAPHER: This is what it
takes to be a pro, hon.
Fantastic.
WOMAN: Girl. Come with me.
EVA: I'm proud of myself
at the fact
that I got through it,
but I'm disappointed
that I showed the vulnerability.
( music playing )
I think everybody is
a little iffy about tomorrow.
TYRA: With elimination coming up
the next day,
Eva felt vulnerable
for the first time.
I gonna get sent home because--
I mean, you know...
MOM: Yeah, but you did good.
If you got through it...
EVA: But it's so few of us
now that are left,
and it's getting down to it,
and any mistake you make,
you know,
could--it could be the end
of it and, I don't know.
It just so frustrating.
TYRA: Even though she was
deathly afraid of spiders...
- Here's your best shot.
- JANICE: Wow.
TYRA: Eva took a beautiful shot
with the tarantula.
You nailed it. It's amazing.
Thank you.
TYRA: But it seem like Toccara
had checked out.
JANICE: How'd you feel
in this--in this photograph?
- Tell me.
- It was a great experience.
- TYRA: That's it?
- TOCCARA: No, I mean...
- Pull it out.
- You're not here.
I am here.
I had a good time.
I was--I was there.
I was, like,
"Ooh, the itty-bitty spider
"is going on my face.
Oh, my God. It's so adorable."
That's...
TYRA: Something's weird.
- JANICE: Yeah.
- You checked out.
NIGEL: You need to install
the personality chip
- back into you.
- Okay.
TYRA: When the girls were
challenged to build
an outfit around a hat,
Yaya went on the defensive.
I did not choose that hat
for the very specific reason,
that is very cliché,
and it has nothing
to do with me.
You know, it's that, like,
realness versus cliché
versus just extra.
And I know I'm very extra,
but it's a different
kind of extra.
TYRA: While the judges
deliberated,
a frustrated Yaya
called her sister.
It's so freaky.
I'm kind of worried about
what it's all gonna
come down to.
And not have all the attention
and animosity...
Sorry, Jazzy. One second.
I can't hear!
I'm on the phone!
Hmm.
Ballistic problem, extra.
( music playing )
TYRA: In the end,
it came down to Toccara and Ann.
The girl's name
that I do not call
shot herself
in the foot tonight.
Why should we care
if she doesn't care?
Ann.
- Thanks, Toccara.
- Thank you.
Bye.
( music playing )
TOCCARA: My next step is taking
all the things
that I've learned here,
taking in
all the constructive criticism,
and going to work.
This is just gonna be a boost.
( music playing )
TYRA: Now, acting
is a big part of modeling,
so I sent the girls to acting
lessons with Sande Shurin,
where they got to perform
with a real star.
Taye Diggs.
- How you doing?
- Oh, Lord!
Oh, Lord. It's Taye Diggs.
- Hi, nice to see you.
- Good to see you.
How Stella Got Her Groove Back.
I loved him in that movie.
( laughing )
Action.
Julia?
Brad, I'm dying.
No.
No, you're not.
EVA: If you haven't forgotten,
I am a doctor,
and the prognosis for
reconstructive cardiomyopathy
- with all these illnesses...
- Hmm.
...is hardly positive.
I did not know
what the hell I was saying.
I've got some ventricular
filling in early diastotle.
The prognosis for...
( music playing )
Remember last spring in Paris?
We strolled down
the Champs-Elysées.
We strolled--
we strolled down the park.
You took me to dinner
- at Le Finite.
- Hmm.
Le Foucault.
- Bradley?
- Are you hot?
AMANDA: I was, like,
"Oh my goodness.
That's Taye Diggs.
Ooh, he's cute. Oh."
- Bradley...
- Hmm.
I can see light coming.
TAYE: Julia.
Good work.
Thank you.
( music playing )
TYRA:
Backstage, the girls recover
from their encounter with Taye.
YAYA: Aha!
EVA: Why are you so red?
It was just so exciting to me.
He kisses you on the face.
I was, like, "Ooh. Okay."
- I kissed his hand.
- Did you?
That was ( ... ) insane.
I love you.
Taye Diggs wants me.
EVA:
Taye Diggs is so married.
- He's married?
- He's so married.
- To who?
- To his wife.
Ah ha!
TYRA: Then I had a script
of my own to read.
Pack your bags, girls,
because you're going to Tokyo.
( screaming )
TYRA: Eva, Ann, and Norelle,
the pink positive roommates,
were happy to be going
to Tokyo together.
NORELLE:
And hopefully one of us
makes it to number one,
and hopefully it's us three.
( music playing )
TYRA: After a 13-hour flight,
I threw the girls right into
the frenzy of Tokyo.
( music playing )
Welcome to Tokyo.
Tokyo is one of the fashion
capitals of the world.
It is the home
of avant-garde fashion.
Their first assignment,
a Campbell's soup commercial.
You girls are going to do
this commercial in Japanese.
NORELLE:
I can barely speak English,
and you want me
to speak Japanese?
EVA: ( speaking in Japanese )
MAN: Cut.
( music playing )
NICOLE: Tyra is telling me
that I don't have
the personality.
Personality,
I don't know who you are,
and I've spent time
with all of you.
NICOLE: My plan was just
to show personality
and blow them away
with my acting.
( speaking in Japanese )
MAN: Cut.
TYRA: Nicole struggled
with the commercial,
but Eva did even worse.
( stumbling over Japanese )
Cut.
EVA: ( speaking in Japanese )
No, no, no.
( speaking in Japanese )
Okay. Do it again, do it again.
TYRA: Eva's weak performance
in the commercial
caused a rift among
the pink positive girls.
I have good pictures, all right?
Stop. So hopefully,
someone with ( ... ) pictures
( ... ) up and they go home.
So who would that be,
me or Norelle?
Me or Norelle?
Clearly not you, Ann.
Eva was, like,
"I hope Norelle bites it."
And I was, like,
"That's not even right,"
because I'm just
as close as Norelle
as I am to Eva now.
EVA: Go ahead and break a leg.
Fall off the ledge, please.
Start.
( speaking in Japanese )
Campbell's Select.
Select the best with--
from Campbell's.
MAN: Cut.
TYRA: At the judging,
the girls had to do
a mock commercial for umeboshi,
an exotic pickled plum.
Hmm, ANTM's "Amebushi"
has--Oh!
ANTM's "Amebushi"
has so much great flavor.
TYRA: But Yaya disrespected
the product.
Mmm! Mmm!
NOLE: You spit out the product.
It was completely insulting
to the client,
to the Japanese people.
TYRA: But the one thing worse
than a bad performance
is one that isn't
memorable at all.
Today, the judges
found it very difficult
to remember anything
about you that stood out.
NICOLE: I tried.
It's just goes to show
that you always
have to be on top
in order to succeed,
and I wasn't.
TYRA: Now five girls remain.
Eva, Controversial Diva.
Ann, the All-American Athlete.
Yaya, the worldly
Ivy League graduate.
Amanda, the free-spirited mom,
who's going blind.
And Norelle,
the Orange County Cinderella.
Don't miss out on the drama
as we find out who will be
America's Next Top Model.
♪ You want to be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na
na na, na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪